[Musique]
l'espagne n'est pas le sont pratiquement
identiques sont la grandeur varient mais
il ya toujours autant de ferveur autour
de ces temples les gens sont très
pratiquants au népal et
on est pris par cette ferveur les gens
font respecte un sens déjà tout dans un
toujours dans le même sens tourneux
aussi les moulins de prière et des fils
leur chapelet effet en plein de fruits
on est dans un temple un temple culturel
quoi c'est ça fait partie du népal ça
devait être avec leur communauté
à y avait des magasins à l'intérieur
cité propre et on avait du shopping par
exemple est et la malle des bouddhistes
en disant triste et belle la pratique et
ils ont du temps non plus un peu partout
et puis ils ont des moulins à prières
pour tourne pas qu'autour de danse
après il ya des traditions comme les
eaux à la réunion la couleur ya de l'eau
d'heure il ya plein de choses qui s'y
passe
c'est impressionnant mystique c'est
qu'on s'est fait bénir bien
avant ça a porté ses fruits
[Musique]
des conditions faciles que ça dans les
nuages
je trouve que c'est un super projet
qu'on attend depuis longtemps parce que
ça fait donc deux ans qu'on en discute
avec les personnes qu'ils organisent et
qu'on trouve très touchant
on trouve que c'est un beau projet que
finalement il ya peut-être un sens ça a
partagé les cultures de la réunion plus
spécifiquement et du népal en tout cas
quand on pense à la france finalement le
la mixité de cultures qu'on peut
retrouver à la réunion le goût pour
justement la danse la musique la
montagne c'est finalement qui est très
présente dans la culture ça ça peut
avoir du sens avec
avec la culture népalaise
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
k